PROFESSOR: We have to
ask what happens here?
This series for h of u
doesn't seem to stop.
You go a 0, a 2, a 4.
Well, it could go on forever.
And what would happen
if it goes on forever?
So if it goes on
forever, let's calculate
what this aj plus 2 over
aj as j goes to infinity.
Let's see how the
coefficients vary
as you go higher and higher
up in the polynomial.
That should be an
interesting thing.
So I pass the aj that is on
the right side and divide it,
and now on the
right-hand side there's
just this product of factors.
And as j goes to
infinity, it's much larger
than 1 or e, whatever
it is, and the 2
and the 1 in the denominator.
So this goes like
2j over j squared.
And this goes roughly
like 2 over j.
So as you go higher and higher
up, by the time j is a billion,
the next term is 2
divided by a billion.
And they are decaying,
which is good,
but they're not
decaying fast enough.
That's a problem.
So let's try to figure out
if we know of a function that
decays in a similar way.
So you could do
it some other way.
I'll do it this way.
e to the u squared-- let's
look at this function--
is this sum from n
equals 0 to infinity 1
over n u squared to the n.
So it's u to the 2n--
1 over n factorial, sorry.
So now, since we have j's
and they jump by twos,
these exponents also
here jump by two.
So that's about right.
So let's think of 2n being
j, and therefore this
becomes a sum where j equals 0,
2, 4, and all that of 1 over--
so even j's.
2n is equal to j--
so j over 2 factorial over 1,
and then you have u to the j.
So if I think of this as some
coefficient c sub j times u
to the j, we've learned
that c sub j is equal to 1
over j divided by two factorial.
In which case, if
that is true, let's
try to see what this
cj plus 2 over cj--
the ratio of two consecutive
coefficients in this series.
Well, cj plus 2 would be j plus
2 over 2 factorial, like this.
That's the numerator,
because of that formula.
And the denominator would
have just j over 2 factorial.
Now, these factorials
make sense.
You don't have to worry that
they are factorials of halves,
because j is even.
And therefore, the numerators
are even-- divided by 2.
These are integers.
These are ordinary factorials.
There are factorials
of fractional numbers.
You've seen them probably
in statistical physics
and other fields, but we
don't have those here.
This is another thing.
So this cancels.
If you have a number and the
number plus 1, which is here,
you get j plus 2 over 2,
which is 2 over j plus 2.
And that's when j
is largest, just 2
over j, which is exactly
what we have here.
So this supposedly
nice, innocent function,
polynomial here--
if it doesn't truncate, if
this recursive relation keeps
producing more and more
and more terms forever--
will diverge.
And it will diverge like so.
If the series does
not truncate, h of u
will diverge like
e to the u squared.
Needless to say,
that's a disaster.
Because, first, it's kind of
interesting to see that here,
yes, you have a safety factor,
e to the minus u squared over 2.
But if h of u diverges
like e to the u squared,
you're still in trouble.
e to the u squared
minus u squared over 2
is e to the plus
u squared over 2.
And it actually coincides
with what we learned before,
that any solution goes like
either plus or minus u squared
over 2.
So if h of u doesn't
truncate and doesn't
become a polynomial,
it will diverge
like e to the u squared, and
this solution will diverge
like e to the plus
u squared over 2,
which was a possibility.
And it will not be normalizable.
So that's basically the
gist of the argument.
This differential
equation-- whenever
you work with
arbitrary energies,
there's no reason why
the series will stop.
Because e there will have to
be equal to 2j plus 1, which
is an integer.
So unless je is an
integer, it will not stop,
and then you'll
have a divergent--
well, not divergent; unbounded--
far of u that is
impossible to normalize.
So the requirement that the
solution be normalizable
quantizes the energy.
It's a very nice effect of
a differential equation.
It's very nice
that you can see it
without doing
numerical experiments,
that what's going on here
is an absolute requirement
that this series terminates.
So here, phi of u
would go like e to
the u squared over 2,
what we mentioned there,
and it's not a solution.
So if the series must
terminate, the numerator
on that box equation must
be 0 for some value of j,
and therefore there must
exist a j such that 2j plus 1
is equal to the energy.
So basically, what this means
is that these unit-free energies
must be an odd integer.
So in this case, this can be
true for j equals 0, 1, 2, 3.
In each case, it will
terminate the series.
With j equals 0, 1, 2, or 3
there, you get some values of e
that the series will terminate.
And when this series terminates,
aj plus 2 is equal to 0.
Because look at
your box equation.
aj, you got her number,
and then suddenly you
get this 2j plus 1 minus e.
And if that's 0, the
next one is zero.
So, yes, you get
something interesting
even for j equals 0.
Because in that case,
you can have a0,
but you will have no
a2, just the constant.
So I will write it.
So if aj plus 2 is
equal to zero, h of u
will be aj u to the j plus
aj minus 2u to the j minus 2.
And it goes down.
The last coefficient
that exists is aj,
and then you go down by two's.
So let's use the
typical notation.
We call j equals n, and then
the energy is 2n plus 1.
The h is an u to the
n plus an minus 2.
You do the n minus
2, and it goes on.
If n is even, it's
an even solution.
If n is odd, it's
an odd solution.
And the energy e, remember,
was h omega over 2 times e--
so 2n plus 1.
So we'll move the
2 in, and e will
be equal to h omega n plus 1/2.
And n in all these solutions
goes from 0, 1, 2, 3.
We can call this the energy en.
So here you see
another well-known,
famous fact that energy
levels are all evenly spaced,
h omega over 2,
one by one by one--
except that there's
even an offset for n
equals 0, which is supposed
to be the lowest energy
state of the oscillator.
You still have a
1/2 h bar omega.
This is just saying that
if you have the potential,
the ground state is
already a little bit up.
You would expect that--
you know there's no solutions
with energy below the lowest
point of the potential.
But the first solution
has to be a little bit up.
So it's here and then
they're all evenly spaced.
And this begins with
E0; for n equals 0, e1.
And there's a little bit
of notational issues.
We used to call the
ground state energy
sometimes e1, e2, e3,
going up, but this time
it is very natural to call it
E0 because it corresponds to n
equals 0.
Sorry.
Those things happen.
No, it's not an approximation.
It's really, in a sense,
the following statement.
Let me remind everybody
of that statement.
When you have even
or odd solutions,
you can produce a
solution that you
may say it's a superposition,
but it will not be an energy
eigenstate anymore.
Because the even solution
that stops, say, at u to the 6
has some energy,
and the odd solution
has a different energy.
So these are different
energy eigenstates.
So the energy
eigenstates, we prove
for one-dimensional
potentials, are not
chosen to be even or
odd for bound states.
They are either even or odd.
You see, a superposition--
how do we say like that?
Here we have it.
If this coefficient is
even, the energy sum value--
if this coefficient is odd,
the energy will be different.
And two energy eigenstates with
different energies, the sum
is not an energy eigenstate.
You can construct the general
solution by superimposing,
but that would be
general solutions
of the full time-dependent
Schrodinger equation, not of
the energy eigenstates.
The equation we're
aiming to solve there
is a solution for
energy eigenstates.
And although this concept I
can see now from the questions
where you're getting,
it's a subtle statement.
Our statement was,
from quantum mechanics,
that when we would solve
a symmetric potential,
the bound states would turn
out to be either even or odd.
It's not an approximation.
It's not a choice.
It's something forced on you.
Each time you find the bound
state, it's either even
or it's odd, and this
turned out to be this case.
You would have said the general
solution is a superposition,
but that's not true.
Because if you put
a superposition,
the energy will
truncate one of them
but will not truncate
the other series.
So one will be bad.
It will do nothing.
So if this point is
not completely clear,
please insist later,
insist in recitation.
Come back to me office hours.
This point should
be eventually clear.
Good.
So what are the names
of these things?
These are called
Hermite polynomials.
And so back to the
differential equation,
let's look at the
differential equations
when e is equal to 2n plus 1.
Go back to the
differential equation,
and we'll write d second
du squared Hn of u.
That will be called the Hermite
polynomial, n minus 2udHn du
plus e minus 1.
But e is 2n plus 1 minus 1
is 2n Hn of u is equal to 0.
This is the Hermite's
differential equation.
And the Hn's are
Hermite polynomials,
which, conventionally,
for purposes
of doing your algebra nicely,
people figured out that Hn of u
is convenient if--
it begins with u
to the n and then
it continues down
u to the n minus 2
and all these ones here.
But here people like it when
it's 2 to the n, u to the n--
a normalization.
So we know the leading
term must be u to the n.
If you truncate with j,
you've got u to the j.
You truncate with n,
you get u to the n.
Since this is a linear
differential equation,
the coefficient in
front is your choice.
And people's choice has been
that one and has been followed.
A few Hermite
polynomials, just a list.
H0 is just 1.
H1 is 2u.
H2 is 4u squared minus 2.
H3 is our last one, 8u
cubed minus 12u, I think.
I have a little typo here.
Maybe it's wrong.
So you want to generate
more Hermite polynomials,
here is a neat way
that is used sometimes.
And these, too, are
generating functional.
It's very nice actually.
You will have in some
homework a little discussion.
Look, you put the
variable z over there.
What is z having to
do with anything?
u we know, but z, why?
Well, z is that formal
variable for what is
called the generating function.
So it's equal to the sum
from n equals 0 to infinity.
And you expand it kind
of like an exponential,
zn over n factorial.
But there will be functions
of u all over there.
If you expand this exponential,
you have an infinite series,
and then you have to collect
terms by powers of z.
And if you have
a z to the 8, you
might have gotten from
this to the fourth,
but you might have gotten
it from this to the 3
and then two
factors of this term
squared or a cross-product.
So after all here, there
will be some function of u,
and that function is called
the Hermite polynomial.
So if you expand this
with Mathematica,
say, and collect
in terms of u, you
will generate the
Hermite polynomials.
With this formula,
it's kind of not
that difficult to see that
the Hermite polynomial begins
in this way.
And how do you
check this is true?
Well, you would have to show
that such polynomials satisfy
that differential
equation, and that's
easier than what it seems.
It might seem difficult,
but it's just a few lines.
Now, I want you to feel
comfortable enough with this,
so let me wrap it
up, the solutions,
and remind you, well, you had
always u but you cared about x.
So u was x over a.
So let's look at
our wave functions.
Our wave functions phi n of x
will be the Hermite polynomial
n of u, which is
of x over a, times
e to the minus u squared over
2, which is minus x squared
over 2a squared.
And you should remember that a
squared is h bar over m omega.
So all kinds of funny factors--
in particular,
this exponential is
e to the minus x squared m
omega over h squared over 2.
I think so-- m
omega over 2h bar.
Let me write it differently--
m omega over 2h bar x squared.
That's that exponential, and
those are the coefficients.
And here there should be
a normalization constant,
which I will not write.
It's a little messy.
And those are the solutions.
And the energies en were h
bar omega over 2 n plus 1/2,
so E0 is equal to
h bar omega over 2.
E1 is 3/2 of h bar omega, and
it just goes on like that.